E aí
E por que você come o que come se eu
fizer essa pergunta para cada um que tá
aqui alguns responderam que não comem
carne porque são vegetarianos uns correm
a comida simplesmente pela praticidade
alguns dirão que ia vir tão comer glúten
por intolerância e certo também que
outros dirão que nunca sequer tinham
parado para pensar nisso bom eu penso
muito em comida eu nasci Numa família de
Paranaguá uma cidade histórica aqui do
litoral do Paraná que alimentação era um
assunto sério uma família repleta de
cozinheiras e mãos cheias daquelas que
quando Reunidas já almoçam pensando no
cardápio da janta
e eu passei boa parte da minha infância
por lá por isso muitas de minhas
memórias de criança tem sabor e até
naquelas memórias que não são contadas
Por que éramos pequenos demais para
lembrar tem comida uma das histórias que
eu mais ouvi na vida conta que quando eu
ainda era muito bebê meu bisavô eu me
preparava pirão de peixe e a linha e
antes de me alimentar ele inspecionava
cada colherada com uma lupa a calça de
eventuais espinhos eu cresci as idas à
Paranaguá se tornaram menos frequentes
mas com certeza foi por muito disso que
eu me tornei cozinheira e mesmo tendo
trabalhado em vários restaurantes foi
como cientista social que eu comecei a
aprender a ver o alimento não só como
ingrediente ou um amontoado de
nutrientes e calorias mas sim como uma
maneira de olhar para o mundo
e comer uma coisa complexa nós somos uma
espécie onívora que compartilha a
necessidade de se alimentar para
sobreviver Mas nem tudo o que é
potencialmente nutritivo em nosso
entorno Nós consideramos comida eu
comecei perguntando as razões de comemos
o que comemos porque escolhas que
pensamos serem só individuais na verdade
reflete uma dimensão coletiva
A Comida fora de nossos afetos memórias
identidade mas também indicações
políticas econômicas históricas e por aí
vai como escrever o livro trouxe um
antropólogo a comida a comida de uma
sociedade é começou a linguagem a e na
nossa sociedade que histórias Conta essa
linguagem se a filósofa Angela Davis
escreveu que o modo com o qual nos
relacionamos com a comida demonstra que
a mercantilização se tornou a principal
maneira pela qual percebemos o mundo nos
dias de hoje em alguma medida é porque
somos herdeiros de uma tradição de
pensamento ocidental quatro arcal
moderna e racional que nos faz crer que
como seres de cantores de Cultura seres
que cozinham estamos separados da
natureza e mais do que isso a dominamos
Só que essa história cobra o seu preço
EA crise ambiental escancaram a
insustentabilidade Desse nosso jeito de
viver e comer e talvez as informações do
mundo pede passa justamente por uma
desmercantilização da nossa percepção a
começar sobre aquilo que tá no nosso
prato todos os dias eu vou mostrar esse
argumento contando uma história sobre o
milho
bom e quando eu falo de cereal talvez a
primeira imagem que vem a vocês a gente
vai ficar como esta amarela com seus
grãozinhos alinhado e uniformes mas há
uns bons milênios o milho mais se
parecia com esse denominado tunicado
porque cada uma de suas sementes em
volta numa túnica de palha
e foi ação humana de manuseio e seleção
entendida pelos povos originarios o
território que hoje chamamos América que
possibilitou o cultivo de cereal ao
longo de todo o continente e também a
existência de variedade tão diferentes
do milho
e hoje arqueologia nos mostra evidências
o cultivo do cereal no norte da América
a cerca de nove mil anos na região
Amazônica a cerca de 6.000 anos
e essa dedicação dos nossos ancestrais
vamos aqui em só que hoje chamamos de
agricultura é conhecida como revolução
neolítica e a gente aprende lá na escola
que foi com esse advento da dominação da
domesticação de espécies agrícolas que
nós evoluímos tem até uma frase que diz
que toda grande civilização que se fez a
partir do contigo de um grão
eu me incomodo muito com essa história
de dominação do Homem com H maiúsculo e
não creio que a existência de todos os
seres viventes do planeta acaba nessa
única narrativa Universal que conta da
vitória da cultura sobre a natureza EA
esse respeito a disseminação do Milho
oferece elementos muito interessantes
o primeiro que o milho diferente de
outras espécies não se multiplica
espontaneamente não existem minerais
naturais por aí é necessária a ação
humana de selecionar as espigas secar as
sementes e replantá-las e foram esses
milênios e técnicas originárias
acumuladas que permitiram que cereal
fosse elevado do continente americano
por volta dos comerciais portugueses lá
nas primeiras décadas do Século 16
espalhando-se pelo mundo até se
transformar na base igual a parte da
nossa alimentação nos dias de hoje
literalmente
e eu sei que essa história pode até
parecer um grande caso de sucesso da
cultura sobre a natureza Afinal nós
domesticamos uma espécie agrícola em
prol do nosso apetite
mas eu aprendi a olhar para essa
história de um outro ângulo a alguns
anos quando eu voltei para Paranaguá
para fazer meu trabalho de pesquisa do
mestrado como o mapa mostra eu voltei
para perto do gigante do porto da cidade
a última ou trabalhou a vida toda e esse
pedaço de Terra Verde ali é uma ilha
praticamente inteira demarcada como
Terra indígena onde há duas teclado duas
aldeias do Povo enviar Guarani e eu fui
para uma delas onde a preservação de uma
variedade de milho muito especial o
abate ter
e além de ser Central na culinária o
abate é protagonista na agricultura e
nas celebrações
e as mulheres Guarani prepara uma comida
feita desse milho guardam as espigas a
cada colheita E vamos trocando as e
transmitindo-as de geração em geração
é a história que a gente já contam sobre
esse cultivo o Entra lá sua própria
existência e quem vai a pouca extensão
dos motivos que eles mantém na
atualidade logo entendi que não se trata
de uma questão só de subsistência mas
sim de resistência Afinal nós estamos
bem distantes do ciclo Colonial da
cana-de-açúcar Mas é para onde remontam
às Raízes do atual sistema de
monoculturas a divisão do território em
grandes latifúndios o cultivo extenso de
uma única espécie EA produção em prol da
produtividade preferem sementes
padronizadas e lucrativas ante a
diversidade das sementes tradicionais
vocês sabiam que solo germoplasma da
Embrapa existem cerca de quatro mil
variedades de milho
e
quando se trata do manejo de uma espécie
o que se busca é sempre alguma
aprimoramento mas existem tecnologias
baseadas em multi-diversidade e
comunidade com outros povos originarios
e tecnologias que simplesmente a buscar
lucro e foi o que aconteceu com o milho
mercantilizado Ao Extremo e transformado
em commodity nas últimas décadas do
século 20 a partir de quando o cultivo
começou a crescer exponencialmente até
chegarmos a impressionante Estimativa de
mais de 65 milhões de toneladas só na
safra brasileira 2020/2021
o palhaça a safra total de alimentos
cultivados o nosso país nesse período
deve chegar perto das 269 milhões de
toneladas é um recorde e outros números
impressionantes exorbitantes que o nosso
país apresenta nesse mesmo período
Infelizmente são os crescentes índices
de fome e segurança alimentar como é
possível nesse cenário Celebrar cifra de
exportação
Oi hoje a fome não é uma questão de
falta de comida mas talvez seja fruto
direto da nossa percepção mercantilizada
de Mundo da congelada ele falava
Oi e essa é só uma dimensão do problema
para outra dimensão nós podemos olhar
nos perguntando Afinal para onde vai
tanto milho bom eu arrisco dizer que é
praticamente impossível que algum de
vocês não tenha consumido milho no dia
de hoje talvez não diretamente mas
saibam que mais a metade da colheita de
a ração para produção animal e na
indústria alimentícia o que sobra desse
milho vai no macarrão instantâneo Nossa
salsicha no sorvete na bala de goma na
cerveja não refrigerante e também em
adesivos é cosméticos medicamentos
tecidos e muito mais de comer tanto
mesmo assim dessa forma não tem comer
menos diversidade e não é à toa que hoje
ia perguntar nos dedos de uma mão as
espécies são base da alimentação do
mundo todo
e será que deveríamos mesmo estar
celebrando a Vitória da cultura sobre a
natureza
E aí eu comecei falando que os alimentos
carregam histórias a história que essa
forma de consumir o milho conta
evidencia a perda de diversidade a perda
de vida que o nosso módulo comer
alimenta
o que o contrário dessa imagem mostra é
que na contramão das práticas monótonas
estão as tecnologias dos povos
originarios Existem muitos estudos e
pesquisas que constatam a importância
das técnicas de manejo empregados por
essas populações na preservação da
biodiversidade nas quais a ação das
mulheres é fundamental e é mais do que
preservar essas Pesquisas mostram até a
ação originária na criação de florestas
como é o caso das matas de Araucárias
aqui no certo com aqui em Curitiba Todos
os anos nos alimentam com pinhões e que
foram cultivados pelos povos caingangue
há mais de um milênio
e eu cresci em Paranaguá sem saber da
origem indígena da cidade muito menos
dessa influência daquela comida de que
me lembro tanto sem saber que a poucos
metros daquele Porto gigantesco e que
meu avô Trabalhava cresciam os pés de
milho Guarani
e em campo Vênus enormes navios passando
sem cessar carregando as toneladas de
grãos dessa safras recordes as eu
aprendi que o alimento também mostra
mundo sim disputa não é o nosso o mundo
do Progresso da dominação humana em que
a comida virou mercadoria e tem que
fabrica padronizado e descartável o
outro é um mundo em que a comida carrega
o vínculo com o território com a vida
não-humana com os que vieram e com os
que virão
é nas palavras do Ailton krenak um
Pensador e Líder indígena esse nosso
mundo nega as formas plurais de vida e
suprime a diversidade em pão de um mesmo
cardápio para todos à base de violência
e Destruição que se refletem no nosso
prato
e não é possível seguir agindo como se
estas fossem problemas distantes que não
os afetam a filósofa vandana Shiva
também Nos alerta que um dos reflexo
desse modo mercantilizado de vida é o
empobrecimento das nossas imaginações
encabrestados por uma monocultura das
lentes
a transformar radicalmente o nosso
sistema agroalimentar é transformar
radicalmente o mundo e o que a história
do Milho conta é que há muitas boas
respostas nós tecnologias ancestrais
nessas vozes que nos anunciam com outro
mundo que não esse da mercantilização
esse nosso mundo das monoculturas do
pensar do viver e do comer bom e como
bem escreveu o Eduardo Galeano som como
futuras essas vozes ancestrais e eu só
espero que ainda tenhamos tempo de
escalas obrigada tá